[Musique]
raffi dans l'oreillette on est avec
cogeco et qu'il faut aller voir en
spectacle un je vous dis qu i qui sera
d'ailleurs pour sa dernière
représentation 100% libre le 28 avril
lors de son anniversaire ce sera aux
folies bergère je serai je passerai le
voir et si tu veux que je fasse
n'importe quoi je le ferai pour toi
il y a laurent baffie dans ton oreille
sébastien cauet célestin bravant procédé
durant l'apéro sur la lotus va devoir
répondre tout ce que tu dis laurent
baffie encore sims et des questions très
simples signé mois sur les règles du jeu
oui je dois répéter ce qu'il dit mais ce
que je dois faire
oui oh oui oh oui c'est quoi tout ce
qu'il dit d'octobre ou au début je dis
quoi non je viens c'est le renard pardon
c'est laurent met un doigt dans le cul
un magot remords je ne mettrai pas un
doigt dans les fesses de magloire
m
accessible que ça voilà balala a les
mots qu est question toi qui a été
l'assistant d' arthur l'animateur télé
sa plus grande qualité
par contre il te déteste il te déteste
il souhaite tellement chaque jour il
souhaite d'abord chaque jour tu sais
bien que je t'aime c'est que la
télévision alors qu'elle est bien
évidemment que c'est pas ma plus grande
qualité d'artiste l'argent l'argent
l'animateur télé que tu détestes jean
luc reichmann quoi c'est une tâche et
c'est à 10 il a dit c'est une tâche mais
je ne peux pas c'est drôle jean luc est
le premier à rigoler comment on date
dans le nord on propose 20 euros à sa
soeur bas parra propose 20 euros à sa
soeur quoi
[Applaudissements]
ban s'est dit oh toi qui es picard tuer
mais femme frigide toi qu'est tunisien
thème quand laich la boulette
franchement c'est bien ça qu'est ce qui
t'a donné envie de faire de la télé ah
bon quand je vais tourner et vous est ce
que gagne et arthur je me suis dit je
peux le faire quand j'ai vu ton niveau
et que j'ai vu ce que gagne et arthur je
me suis dit je peux le faire
ça me fait beaucoup de peine que tu
critiques arthur déjà ça me dégoûte que
tu me mettre dans le même sac encore
plus avec quelle femme ouvre à great tu
d'avoir une rue une aventure à part ta
mère tu veux dire j'en étais servent pas
les ballons mais ça te fait rire sa voix
leur sied pas ta maman quand même mais
dit lui-même tout cas merci pour ta mère
elle est moins chère que massa il a dit
en tout cas merci pour ta mère les mois
chaque ma soeur mais bon
voici partiront pas les ballons bah
merci laurent baffie merci cauet a tenu
son pari